Welcome to this explainer on character
encoding.
Okay, so in our first session, we
absolutely nailed number bases and binary
arithmetic. You already know exactly how
computers crunch numbers using just ones
and zeros. But today, we're going to build
on that knowledge and figure out exactly
how computers manage to store, sort, and
understand the actual text you type.
How do we get from a letter on a screen to
a binary number in a processor?
Let's find out. Here is the roadmap for
today's revision.
Translating text, the ASCII standard,
calculating codes, the Unicode solution,
ASCII versus Unicode, and finally, sorting
data.
But before we really dive in, just look
down at your keyboard for a second.
How on earth does the physical tap of a
plastic key actually transform into those
electrical ones and zeros we tackled in
lesson one?
There's got to be some kind of middle
step, right?
A translator? Section one, translating
text and the core problem we face.
Well, since computers literally only
understand binary, we need a bulletproof,
universally agreed upon system to convert
our letters, punctuation, and symbols into
numbers. And this is exactly what we call
a character set.
You definitely want to memorize this
definition for your exam.
It's the agreed list that maps each
character to its unique binary code.
It's kind of like a secret decoder ring.
Every single letter you type gets assigned
a unique number, which is then stored as
its binary equivalent.
Without this shared set, a file you make
on your laptop would just look like
absolute gibberish if you emailed it to a
friend.
Moving on to section two, the ASCII
standard, our 7-bit pioneer.
So early computer scientists tackled this
exact translation problem with something
called the American Standard Code for
Information Interchange, or as we all call
it, ASCII. It gave early computers a
common language, and by using exactly 7
bits per character, it gave them exactly
128 unique codes, ranging from 0 to 127.
Why 128? Well, 2 to the power of 7 is 128.
These 128 characters cover the basics.
Uppercase and lowercase alphabet, digits 0
through 9, basic punctuation, and a few
control things like hitting the enter key
for a new line.
Okay, listen up, because this is
absolutely crucial.
You literally must memorize these three
magic starting numbers for your exam.
Uppercase A is 65, lowercase A is 97, and
the digit 0 is 48.
Why is this such a big deal? Because the
whole genius behind ASCII is that the
codes are grouped and perfectly
sequential.
If A is 65, it just naturally follows that
B is 66, C is 67, and so on.
If you know one code in a group, you can
figure out the entire rest of the set.
Section 3, calculating codes, or as I like
to call it, exam detective work.
Because these codes are perfectly
sequential, AQA examiners love, and I mean
love, asking you to calculate character
codes.
It's easy points once you know the trick.
Let's say your exam asks for the ASCII
code for an uppercase G. Step one,
identify the starting code.
We know A is 65, right? Step two,
calculate the offset.
A is the first letter, G is the seventh.
That means G is exactly six letters away
from A. Step three, just add that offset
to the starting code.
65 plus 6 equals 71. Boom, G is 71.
And you know, it works backwards too. If
an exam says a character has the code 100,
just remember lowercase a is 97. 100 minus
97 is 3.
Count three letters forward from a, b, c,
d.
The character is lowercase d. Now this
brings us to a notorious exam trap.
I see this all the time. The text
character of a number is absolutely not
the same as the mathematical value of that
number.
Remember earlier, the text character for
the digit 0 starts at ASCII code 40.
So counting up seven spots means the text
character seven actually has an ASCII code
of 55. It is completely 100% different
from the mathematical integer seven that
you'd use in, say, an addition problem.
All right, section four, the Unicode
solution, our modern hero. So while ASCII
was awesome for early English-speaking
scientists, it had a massive flaw.
Absolutely zero space for accented
letters, Chinese characters, Arabic
script, or, you know, the emojis you use
every single day. ASCII just couldn't
handle it.
Enter Unicode. Unicode was developed using
more bits per character to solve exactly
this problem. By doing that, Unicode
completely blew past that tiny 128
character limit, giving us a massive,
mind-blowing capacity of over 1 million
distinct characters. That's literally
enough for every single writing system
currently in use on planet Earth, plus
dead historical scripts, obscure
mathematical symbols, and yes, literally
every emoji you can think of.
Okay, this next concept is a massive
keyword for AQA, so remember this:
backwards compatible. When they designed
Unicode, they made a genius decision.
Unicode uses exactly the same codes as
ASCII for the first 128 characters.
Uppercase A is still 65 in Unicode,
exactly like it was in ASCII.
This backwards compatibility means an old
ASCII text file from, say, the 1980s can
be read seamlessly by a modern Unicode
system today, without any translation or
conversion needed whatsoever. Moving to
section 5, ASCII versus Unicode and the
inevitable trade-off. Let's distill all
this down so you can easily weigh the pros
and cons in your exam. It's basically a
trade-off.
ASCII uses just 7 bits per character,
which means it has very low storage
requirements. It's incredibly efficient if
you literally only need basic English
text. Unicode, on the other hand, uses
more bits per character to pull off its 1
million plus capacity. So the trade-off
here is storage space.
A Unicode text file is always going to
require more storage space per character
than an ASCII file. But honestly, on
modern hardware where we have gigabytes
and terabytes of memory, this trade-off is
absolutely worth it to enable true global
communication. And that's exactly why
virtually every modern browser and
operating system just defaults to Unicode
now.
Finally, section 6, sorting data,
specifically using lexicographic order.
So think about when you click sort
alphabetically in a spreadsheet.
What is the computer actually doing behind
the scenes?
Well, computers don't inherently
understand the alphabet.
They just understand numbers, right? So
they sort text by comparing the character
codes numerically. We call this
lexicographic order.
A comes before B for the simple fact that
65 is less than 66.
But here's the crazy part. Because all
uppercase letters are grouped from 65 to
90, and lowercase letters don't even start
until 97, a simple computer sort will
shockingly put a capital Z before a
lowercase A.
Why? Because 90 is less than 97. It's as
simple as that.
And actually, this brilliantly explains
that classic programming glitch you've
probably seen, where a list weirdly sorts
to number 10 before the number 9.
If the computer thinks it's sorting text
instead of math, it just looks at the very
first character of the string. The text
character 1 has an ASCII code of 49.
The text character 9 has an ASCII code of
57.
Because 49 is less than 57, the computer
confidently just slaps 10 right at the top
of the list. Understanding these character
sets explains exactly why these weird
little bugs happen. You know, you have now
totally mastered how we translate simple
text into binary ones and zeros using
character sets.
But as we look ahead to our next explainer
in this data representation unit, I really
want you to start wondering about
something big.
If it takes this much thought and
processing just to turn the letter A into
a number, what kind of mathematical magic
do we need to turn a vibrant million-color
photograph into pure binary? Keep that
rattling around in your head, and I'll see
you in the next lesson where we conquer
representing images and sound.
See you then.